on february 24th russian forces invaded
ukraine
for weeks the united states and the west
had warned of an impending military
offensive russian president vladimir
putin called it a special operation to
denazify and demilitarize ukraine
but while the east and west narratives
clash the death toll and destruction
keeps on rising
the front line in this war is not only
military it's also financial and
political for both sides of the conflict
some european countries like germany
highly reliant on russian gas and oil
have refused to accept a complete energy
embargo on russia other eu member states
like poland fearing a possible
aggression on its soil wants europe to
be less reliant on russian energy
resources
poland has taken in more ukrainian
refugees than any other eu nation
and it's been a crucial transit point
for nato weapons heading to ukraine
but what's warsaw's plan to prevent a
possible escalation of the conflict and
how can europe be entirely free of its
dependence on russian oil and gas
we'll put those questions to poland's
deputy foreign minister as we caught up
with him at the doha forum 2022
world leaders and policymakers came
together to discuss geopolitical
alliances economic development security
and ways the world can transform for a
new era
pavel yablonsky talks to al jazeera
pavio yablonski the deputy foreign
minister of poland thank you so much for
talking to al jazeera hello thank you
for having me our pleasure let's start
with the war in ukraine has it made the
possibility of conflict between poland
and by extension of course nato and
between russia more likely now
this
reality is what we are living with for
many years and we
know very well in poland and other
countries in central europe
that this has always been very very real
russia is a country of a very aggressive
nature
russia governed by vladimir putin has
been doing a lot of aggressive things
for the last two decades since he took
over in 1999 he immediately attacked
chechnya he inflicted war on civilian
populations he went on murdering his
political opponents in russia he
attacked georgia in 2008 he attacked
ukraine in 2014 he occupies crimea and
saw east ukraine but do you feel that
poland is now being targeted more than
in the past certainly we are because
putin is only
not attacking other countries because
today
he doesn't have adequate resources he
certainly would be willing to attack if
he knew that he can win that he can
execute this drug and succeed but how
are you being increasingly targeted do
you feel by russia these days oh just
over the course of recent days we've
been hearing open calls for for example
this
absurd narrative of denasification now
this is what potent was using to justify
his attack ukraine that allegedly there
are some some nazis ruling this country
even though the president of ukraine is
jewish and now our members of russian
parliament are saying that there are
another six countries requiring the
nazification including poland so there
is this narrative going on but we are
quite certain now that because of
ukraine is doing today
russia is not capable of attacking other
countries but if we allow putin to win
this war they will rebuild they will
regroup they will resupply and they will
be attacking more countries they will be
starting more wars do you agree then
with what's been reported uh and
attributed to the ukrainian ambassador
to poland andrei jeschitzia who was
quoted as saying russia is preparing to
attack poland do you think vladimir
putin is preparing to attack poland
russia is certainly threatening with
various attacks to
deter west to deter european union nato
from decisive response and this was the
main goal of russian narrative that if
nato does something does one thing or
does not
meet some russian demand putin will
consider this an act of war do you think
it's serious though do you take that as
a serious possibility of of russia
attacking i think there is serious
possibility and there's not there's much
more than syria possibilities absolute
certainty that putin would like to do it
and at the same time we are also quite
certain that he will not do it now
because he's too much occupied with
what's happening in ukraine he's losing
this war he cannot uh overcome brave
ukrainian defense but he's still much
bigger and has much more resources so he
still can overcome that the main task
for us now is to stop him this is the
opportunity this is time to act the
polish foreign ministry spokesman luka
shashina he said that 45 russian
diplomats expelled from poland as i'm
sure you know they were engaging in
activities that were threatening
ukrainian refugees in poland what sort
of threatening activities is he
referring to they were acting as uh a
spice or doing other illegal things now
i'm sure you know if i can present to
you the russian narrative the russian
ambassador opponent said that's nonsense
they were just carrying out their usual
diplomatic activities what do you know
that they were engaging in that was
threatening we are not at liberty to
disclose every information because that
some of them and most of them are
actually classified you can't give me
examples of what
there are attempts for example to
either actions in um
in hybrid
terms for example in disinformation in
creating tensions false narratives to uh
create tensions between ukrainian people
and polish people to
create this form of
well maybe not
entire entire conflict between between
polish nation ukraine nation but try
trying to diminish the support the will
of support on the side of polish people
the support for ukraine which has been
enormous but russia is obviously willing
to diminish it because it sees that
poland is stronger supporting ukraine
and the weaker the support would be
russia would have easier chance to win
the russian narrative is very different
of course as you know they would argue
that actually they have been on the
defensive since the 1990s that it's nato
that is expanding into what was formerly
their sphere of influence how do you
respond to that if russia is saying that
they are in defense
i can't remember any situation where
russia was attacked it was russia that
has been attacking other countries putin
is promising
repeating this false narrative of russia
being encircled by nato russia only
if i remember correctly six percent of
russia land borders
is a border with nato countries so it's
entirely false narrative he repeats this
because he knows that not everybody in
in the global information sphere follows
the facts but this is entirely false is
there any chance do you think that nato
will adopt poland's suggestion to send
armed peacekeepers to ukraine any chance
of that do you see i believe that this
need is uh higher than ever we see
humanitarian catastrophe in ukraine and
so
our first and foremost what we should be
doing our our main goal is to prevent
these hostilities from hurting civilians
well you see that but do you think my
question is do you think nato might see
that please allow me to allow me to to
finish because i think the the the
debate of this has been shaped in a
little uh
maybe not unintended but but the wrong
way
it is obvious that in international
organizations such as nato such as
european union there are various
perspectives there are differences of
opinion there are some proposals that
are not accepted immediately by other
countries that's all understood
but again do you see any chance nato
might approve that and go for it let me
give you an example of another
international organization that also was
reluctant to do some things but then it
changed its mind the european union when
the war broke out in 24 february there
was an emergency meeting of european
council and immediately this was also
convened in the notion of poland and
central european countries immediately
we started about
so to talk about what sanctions should
be should we impose
on this very day there were several
ideas for example excluding russian
banks from the swift system
closing airspace over european union for
russian aircrafts and on february 24th
this was not agreed european union did
not want to do this on the next day in
the morning poland closed its airspace
and we started to convince some other
european countries to do it over the
course of the next 48 hours the whole eu
closed its airspace the same for swift
system
initially there was no agreement a
couple days later we managed together
with other our eyes order our allies to
convince the rest
this is how we need to act also in terms
of other ideas like this this is very
dynamic we need to be flexible we need
to be agile we need to be consistent and
poland is quite consistent in calling
our allies to be more decisive we will
continue to do it and you think then it
sounds like you're saying yes you think
there's a chance nathan there is a
chance if we remain persistent there is
a chance and we hope that there will be
more understanding how much necessary it
is if we talk about the the recent deal
between the u.s and the eu for the us to
provide i think about 15 billion cubic
meters of gas
extra supplies of gas to europe
well despite that we're looking at a
timetable of
the end of the decade before europe can
be weaned off of
russian gas
because they supply something like 155
billion cubic meters
do you think that timetable can be sped
up do you think in other words europe
can move off of russian gas quicker than
that i think it can be done much quicker
even
germany the country that's been among
the most reluctant ones because of the
size of the dependency german minister
habek said that germany will phase out
russian gas until the end of 2024 so
it's much faster end of the decade and
they think it can be done even quicker
especially if we increase our
partnership not just with the us but
also with countries in the gulf
cooperation with the state of qatar
between poland and other european
countries is a great foundation for
central cooperation we should be
increasing that obviously capacity is
limited and there will be
obstacles there will be
troubles but these troubles result from
war they don't result from sanctions the
sooner we are able to end this war the
sooner we are able to stop russian
hostilities not just in ukraine now but
also for the future
we will be able to recover also
economically how soon do you think when
you speak with your european
counterparts what is the timetable in
your mind when do you think that europe
can be off of russian gas i think this
can be done by the end of this year
because of this and that is
actually possible because we are an
economy that is very flexible very agile
we are able to adjust that can be costly
to economies but if we are able to do it
if we are able to cut russia off money
and actually gas is not even that
important much more important thing is
oil
both crude oil and petroleum products
this is three times as important as how
soon do you think on behalf of russian
when it comes to oil it is actually
paradoxically much easier for europe to
do it because there is much easier way
to diversify it when it comes to polish
government and polish economy we started
these steps couple of years ago already
we are able to do it
in one day so to speak we are able to do
it and we are actually considering very
strongly to start our national action if
if the eu does not want to agree on this
we are considering to do it still in
march we will be considering this in the
coming days and probably announcing what
do we want to do also hoping that the
rest will follow because we need to do
it very quickly
if we are looking at how russia economy
looks like now russian economy has
received a lot of a lot of punches so to
say because of of the swift system of
various sanctions this is very badly
damaging the economy
people are actually suffering struggling
to buy basic products but putin doesn't
care about this he only cares about
money that he gets to finance the army
and he gets this money from oil from gas
mostly from those two resources also
from coal in some in some smaller
fraction so if we are able to cut him
off this money now he will have to end
this war otherwise he can continue so
when do you think because this is a very
crucial question as you said you're
talking with your european counterparts
these days
when do you think europe could get off
of russian oil
as well even quicker than from the
russian gas because
oil and all the facilities before the
end of the year even countries that are
still dependent on russian oil germany
is yet another example also in this in
this area they can do it much quicker
they can get suppliers from other
sources
mr yablonsky that's always the question
where can europe get the extra capacity
from the world is quite tight when it
comes to production isn't it when it
comes to gas it's it's more difficult we
agree but when it comes to oil there are
other suppliers obviously this requires
political commitment but there are
possibilities there are options to
increase output especially in the gulf
region this is what president zielenski
has been advocating for and we will also
be talking to our partners here to our
partners in other parts of the world to
increase it because with oil it is
actually much easier there are much more
suppliers than when it comes to gas
there's much less
requiring uh technology uh there are
less requirements to be met when it
comes to shipping so it is easier and
paradoxically this much more important
and would be much more damaging for
russian economy let's talk a little bit
about the middle east since you're not
only poland's deputy foreign minister
you also specialize in the mena region
what would you like to see from this
part of the world
are you asking for more oil and gas i
imagine that's the case and what kind of
response do you feel you're getting are
you getting cooperation we certainly
understand that the position of
countries in the middle east is quite
peculiar that there is also uh presence
of russia and some russian allies here
that does not allow for
uh immediate decision to
be on one side and completely against
russia we understand that this is much
complex at the same time
this is a big opportunity
to display
unity and support for the values that i
believe both europe and majority of the
countries in the gulf hold there that we
believe in territory integrity we
believe in
the sovereignty of nations in the rights
to forfeit nations to the site of their
own future
in the necessity to preserve peace
right now
perhaps more than ever in history europe
needs
countries in the gulf to preserve global
peace this is a huge opportunity to
build
long-standing strategic partnership
between the gulf between arab countries
and europe and not just about it's not
just about exports of energies obviously
very important the cornerstone of our
economies we need to work much more on
that but actually perhaps even more
the political commitment to be on the
same side if we see that there is
aggressor and there is a victim there
shouldn't be any ambiguity who to
support let's talk a little bit about
refugees poland has accepted another
around 2 million refugees from ukraine
since the war began
do you concede though what a lot of
human rights groups organizations have
documented that poland did not extend
the same
legal process asylum process to refugees
and migrants who came to poland's border
from the middle east or predominantly
muslim countries i might mention a
report
of december twentieth 20 2021 by amnesty
international international human rights
group
that documented the case of a group of
75 syrians iraqis and other
nationalities who they say polish
authorities push them back after they
reach the border some of whom had
already entered
polish territory without processing
their asylum claims
and they documented cases of polish
forces pepper spraying families even
children
pushing adults into rivers beating
people with batons do you can see that
was wrong i have to say that these
reports are false unfortunately i know
that those amnesty is wrong and this is
wrong i'm sorry to say this i'm nice to
repeat and
i'm it hurts me to say this because i
used to respect amnesty very much but at
times unfortunately they have been
repeating false belarusian and russian
propaganda this very important
distinction between what's happening now
and what was happening over the course
of summer and autumn last year
the people that are fleeing to poland
right now over 2.2 million already
these are people that are running away
from vladimir putin
back in the autumn in the summer 2021
those were people that putin together
with kashanka brought on our border
these people were not running away from
war in belarus they were
brought there by belarusian forces by
belarusian government organized in
groups and they were pushed by
belarusian forces to our borders this
was something entirely different this
was an attempt to destabilize not just
poland but also other eu countries
we have been always very open
if somebody is running away from war
it's running away from persecution
this is something which we are always
open to we are accepting refugees and
not just of ukrainian nationalities
we've accepted uh refugees of 160
nationalities and ethnicities over the
course of the last six weeks
but what happened then these people were
not running away from war in belarus
there was no war in belarus at the time
belarus was a safe country they had no
legal grounds to be considered refugees
they were trying to be to get there but
they were this was an organized attempt
this was actually a tool of hybrid
warfare but then you're saying not only
amnesty is wrong when it says quote
poland is in clear violation of
international law and standards
including the violation of the
prohibition of torture and other ill
treatment but also
groups like human rights watch which
said in its report of november 2021 when
they documented similar cases of people
from the middle east being pushed back
by polish officials they said polish
authorities need to quote end summary
expulsions
quote stop all the abuses including
violence and theft they're also wrong
you feel no obligation that if someone
comes to your border even if they've
been pushed by belarus but you can see
they're coming from war-torn countries
like syria you don't feel are under any
obligation to even process individually
their asylum claims and see who needs or
not international law is very very clear
on this they should be processed in the
first safe country and in this case
belarus was the country where they
should be processed if they would be
running away from war actually most of
them were not coming from syria they
were coming from northern iraq there is
no war
in northern iraq i understand that
conditions of living northern iraq are
far from ideal to say it very moderately
but
look
if we would agree that everyone that
comes to any border has the right to be
accepted then we would have to
liquidate all borders there would be no
border security at all we cannot allow
this we have quite we have installed
quite a simple procedure we had border
guards across our border not allowing
people to enter obviously there is no
nothing
like 100 percent uh sealed borders so
some people managed to enter our
territories if somebody entered our
territory if they made an application
for asylum they were processed in
accordance with the law this is this is
allow me to finish these alleged
pushbacks
are referred to a situation where people
were detained at attempting to cross the
border immediately obviously this is the
duty of the border guards not to allow
people to cross illegally what should
they do they should allow them to to get
inside there there would be no place for
border guards should they pepper spray
children and they were pepper spraying
people that were attacking
our border guards our police there are
videos of this they were not peppers
praying nobody who wasn't attacking them
there are videos of these groups of
migrants they were actually not women
and children there were young men
attacking they were equipped with some
tools by belarusian forces they were
throwing stones they were they were
cutting trees to use as as tools to
attack our border guards there are
videos of this our border guys were not
attacking nobody without
the need to defend themselves why do you
think your understanding of
international law is so different from
amnesty international from human rights
watch from even the european court of
justice in its 2020 ruling rejected
poland's argument
that it can reject refugee quotas based
on internal security why do you think
you understand they seem to have a
different understanding of international
law that if somebody makes it to your
territory you have to at least process
their asylum claims are you saying
they're all wrong including the european
court of justice our understanding of
the international law is displayed every
day
on the border with ukraine for over a
month now
everybody that comes to our border of
ukrainian nationality of 160 other
nationalities
is admitted is accepted is given shelter
food we're providing everything we can
we've actually passed the law that
allows refugees to get access to
healthcare education to be part of the
fabric of the polish society this is the
approach that we have towards refugees
that are running away from war but the
regulations of international law can
sometimes be abused this was the case
that we were dealing with in autumn last
year that there were some people
pretending to be refugees they were not
running away from war
there was no war in belarus
all these organizations and the european
court of justice and amnesty and human
rights watch are all wrong
help us to understand as a viewer
listening to this how how can they make
sense i think i am quite clear
if somebody runs away from war
they are refugees
if somebody does not run away from war
if somebody wants to cross the border
illegally they're not refugees there was
no war in valorous they can't be more
clear about this
has it got anything to do with what
poland's minister of justice zubignu
jobaro was quoted as telling polish
state broadcaster tvp on april the 5th
2020 when he said quote poland was right
not to accept refugees we defended our
sovereignty against the foreign culture
of islam
was that a right statement to make
is it right to reject somebody based on
their religion i don't actually know
this quote i don't remember if this was
actual quote i think this is this is
entirely wrong
we have nothing against islam against
peaceful coexistence of various
religions we actually have our very
small
but very historically enshrined in our
tradition very small minority of islamic
people in poland in the eastern actually
very close to to do to our eastern
border so this is also even not very
significant but it's also part of our
history of our culture and we have
always been a very embracing culture
towards every
every nation every ethnicity every
religion this was this is a part of our
identity
if somebody said this this was entirely
wrong and a final question do you feel
at least any obligation to investigate
some of these claims which these
organizations have documented of people
who claim they've been pepper sprayed
after entering into polish territory and
being put into security vans
that their kids were pepper sprayed when
they spoke things like that we have
investigated that actually we have
invested why has no action been taken
because because it wasn't it wasn't
proven to be fact they actually have
been purposeful they have been tortured
on the belarusian side this was actually
confirmed that many of these cases were
happening on the ballerina side then
unfortunately because of some i don't
know it was their some ill will or just
some misunderstandings some of these
actions were attributed to what was
happening on the polish border but
let me very clear let me repeat this our
approach to international law to human
rights is displayed every day on the
border with ukraine we are accepting
everyone with no prejudice towards
ethnicity religion or anything else
fabio jablonski the deputy foreign
minister of poland thank you very much
for talking to al jazeera thank you for
having me thank you very much
[Music]
you